pro football talk live here in miami for
super bowl 54 one of the guys who was a
key member of the super bowl 40 champion
pittsburgh steelers hall of famer number
eight all time he's from rushing i
didn't know you were from detroit i had
no idea motown baby
jerome welcome how are you buddy thank
you for having me guys what's the
biggest memory that pops out
for you from super bowl 40
for me was
looking up my my parents were in a box
and my father's no longer here so it was
always looking up at the box seeing them
uh and their enjoyment in that moment
because it wasn't just me you know they
had my mom and dad went to every single
football game i'd ever played for 13
years so this was a culmination for not
only myself but for them as well i'll
tell you what i remember about that day
jerome bettis wins the super bowl in his
hometown and afterwards it's like he's
the pied piper all throughout detroit
and i look up at one point i'm following
you because i'm going to write about you
and i'm following you and i look up and
there's mike tyson and i just said okay
the circus is on everybody is here with
jerome venice it's like you were such a
charismatic magnetic figure at that time
what a night that was it was an
incredible night and and and you know
it was crazy because so many people
magic johnson magic johnson was there
too it was it was great because they
were all you know celebrating the moment
and it was a it was a big moment but in
that moment i was just so wrapped up in
having won the super bowl i wasn't you
know it was great yeah it was great to
see him but after the fact when when you
and other people said man that you had
all these guys were out there at that
party
you know i didn't really think about it
because i was just so immersed in and
haven't won a championship uh because my
whole 13 years the only goal was to win
a championship and i had done it did did
you get nervous before games like i know
quarterbacks get nervous because they
got to worry about all the plays and the
checks and they want to make sure that
like what was what was your mindset my
mindset so i i listened for the majority
of my career i listened to one song and
it was tupac me against the world yeah
and so i would i would just continuously
loop it because my idea was it's just
i've got the mindset when i hit the
field yeah it's me against those 11 guys
right so i was never nervous i was
always you know supremely confident that
i was going to go out there and show out
you were kind of the original beast mode
you know
really oh you're the og beast mode do
you know that well
that was the idea i wanted to impose my
will so i wanted to punish them right as
much as i could and then in the fourth
quarter get a little slippery and make
them missing in because they're worried
about tackling they're on their toes
they're closing their eyes yeah
jerome who's the guy now that you look
at and say i see i see me and him the
guy that's going to make the defenders
close their eyes oh when you see henry i
mean goodness gracious uh right derrick
henry is that guy they don't
they do not want to tackle him you see
guys making business decisions the
entire game they're saying uh maybe from
the side right and then they go from the
side he'd give him a stiff arm and he's
going 90 yards or something like that so
he's uh he's impressive to watch you um
i've always wanted to know this i mean
okay
well all right
like in your heyday i want to know i've
asked you enough football questions what
were you eating all right i want to know
the jerome bettis diet i just don't
think you were like making protein
shakes at home and like counting
calories i never pictured you that way
here's here's what i did i
my diet wasn't a diet it was a day so
certain days so for instance after the
game monday tuesday uh i know whatever
whatever i wanted to eat wednesday was
kind of in between thursday
friday saturday i was always kind of
managing everything i ate and i worked
out at night uh every night uh late in
the week right especially with my legs
because i was getting hit a lot in my
lower body so i would always ride the
bike uh
the latter part of the week and so that
would that would always kind of keep my
weight
in terms of uh in good shape were you
trying to go into a saturday with a
certain weight always and no i was
trying to go with a feeling i didn't
want to feel heavy i didn't want to feel
heavy right i got you my weight was you
know always three or four or five pounds
kind of fluctuating yeah well never too
much
in my prime i was about two fifty seven
two two five six games in between 255
and 258 so right in there right and that
and that's i played i played like that
for about eight eight years and then uh
at my last couple years the three and
six started stretching uh it got tough
so post career post career what has your
health been like how do you feel post
career you know what for the early part
of my i've been retired 14 years so so
there was kind of like for now i've been
two halves so the first couple years was
was pretty good uh you know i was doing
everything
and i had little kids at the time and
and things just started to start to
deteriorate and one big problem i had i
was a big golfer i'm still a big golfer
and as i started playing i started to
feel some pain in my back and then
never really paid much attention to it
because me and payne we had a great
relationship i was able to kind of
manage
the pain but then it got to the point
where i wasn't able to do the things
um with my kids that i wanted to do and
and kind of maintain the quality of life
and so at that point
i said you know i need to make i need to
make a a change i need to find
uh
the right surgery and so i just started
researching uh surgeries different type
of surgeries because i knew i needed
surgery on my back
and i went to the doctor and they said
hey you're going to need it now it's
just a matter of how long you can manage
the pain
uh so i started to research i found um
the the right surgery and it's called
x-lift surgery and it's for the um
fusion in my back and then i found the
right doctor right um and those two are
are critical because certain doctors do
certain types of surgeries and so i
found the surgery and then i wanted to
find the
best
doctor uh that performed that surgery in
the world and the guy's name was dr
uribe and uh he was sensational and so i
was able to have the surgery when did
you have the surgery i had it in march i
believe of 17
and the scary part was
what i had heard was you know hey
they're going to fillet your back they
cut you all open and you know you go in
it's eight month recovery
and doing my research this surgery was
was uh less invasive it was you know
three months they went in from my side
my hip right uh and it didn't have the
big scars on my back yeah my back
muscles were intact so it was just one
of those uh
really it it saved my quality of life in
terms of what i could do with life
what can you do now i do everything i
play golf you know two three times a
week if i can if i'm lucky i'm working
on the handicap trying to get it down
but uh
most importantly
it's the relationship with with my kids
i'm able to play with them i'm teaching
them some basketball football and doing
all those things yeah where where early
on i was really nervous about that and
the story is um if you go online you can
go to nuvasive.com backslash the bus and
my kind of my story is there for people
to see because you know a lot of people
are dealing with back pain that they
don't really have to uh exactly and if
you do some do some research some
homework on it i think um you'll find
that there is there are some solutions
right you just have to find the right
the right
solution yeah i just keep sucking it up
like you say yeah yeah that's right i
just deal with it yeah right well hey
jerome it's great seeing you
congratulations on the hall of fame
career eighth all time on the nfl
rushing list and the running game is
coming back we may see a lot of running
it shouldn't have it should have never
left that's how you guys
should practice more pft live right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports